[Musica]
ogni studio rinata si è vissuto e fatto
che motore di scream è morta cristina
cattaneo capo si chiama tempo perché
avevo un cazzo ciao ragazzi ben tornato
in una puntata di cucina buttata oggi
faremo una cosa molto bella che mi
diverte tantissimo che essermi svegliato
due ore e mezzo fa ma sembra che mi sono
svegliato dieci minuti fa giusto mi
confermi questa cosa è confermato
fatecelo sapere perché se mai mi sono
svegliato perché il romito poco
mannaggia mi ha beccato direi
ad ogni modo ragazzi oggi faremo una
ricetta a parte gli scherzi che io amo
particolarmente
col tempo ho imparato a studiare così
tanto da iniziare anche audia riposte
nei quali non lo fanno bene avete mani
solo quello invece tu e le tue cipolle
pieni di rancore come sono già marcon
sommelier di odio c'è da dire che ormai
fanno tutti il poker noi è diventato
però un prodotto abbastanza dozzinale e
privo di qualità oserei dire e di
equilibrio gusto e generosità ma bando
alle ciance e passiamo agli ingredienti
per fare il nostro può che avremo
bisogno di riso io ho scelto quello
basmati salmone abbattuto nel senso di
triste rocco siffredi vostro onore rocco
siffredi mandorle sesamo semi di
papavero wasabi erba sintetica e soia
per prima cosa aprendo il riso e ragazzi
io utilizzerò una tecnica giapponese che
poi può che eguagliano poi sapete cosa
sto parlando
una roba per far rilasciare la nido
quelle caterino mettiti poi la mollo
nell'acqua
i cambi l'acqua nella basilica enrico
non è vero quello che dicono di te tutti
quanta acqua vedete questa specie di
sbirri già quella leva di minata
dovreste arrivare al momento in cui
proprio l'acqua e bianca a noi oggi c'e
vanno dai facciamolo per i nostri
problemi sono toccati fuoco medio
speriamo di riuscire a fare tutto quanto
bene pregate per me nel frattempo
passiamo ai tagli che i ragazzi la cosa
importante è quello che ci sta sopra e
il modo in cui viene disposto e
soprattutto l'arte con la quale tu
riesce a dipingere il cibo e gli
equilibri di cibo la prima cosa quindi
fondamentale il taglio il taglio di
tutto quello che ci andrà sopra per i
giapponesi della quagliano taglio è
fondamentale come per noi non diremo c'è
la vasta hai fatto un allegoria toccante
o così toccante che se volete riscrivere
a questo canale per continuare a sentire
la poesia di enrico nel prossimo video
per tutti gli iscritti e si scrivono
oggi tira fuori un aforisma che ha tante
parole quanti iscritti a mille iscritti
e una cartella con mille parole discorso
da 3.000 iscritti 10 mila iscritti un
racconto breve ragazzi lo farei
scrivetevi in modo da poter avere nelle
librerie del rito cetriolo ragazzi
questi mi raccomando lavate di sempre si
sa se li avete usati che se non avete
usati cosa mi ricorda un cetriolo
fatemi sapere nei commenti e cosa vi
ricorda questa maglietta quest'onda
veramente fatto apposta
sono giappone e hawaiano sono già buone
afferrate il coltello dalla lama non
ferrate lo così perché così avete un
maggiore controllo del
dalla madre quando ci sposteremo nella
nuova cucina la produzione mi può dare
un coltello che tagli bene
altra domanda siccome dobbiamo iniziare
daccapo praticamente a mettere tutte
quante le robin 1 cucina quali sono
delle cose che secondo me dovrebbero
stare in una cucina professionale di
qualcosa per fare le cose fiamme
cabriolet fuhrer si pone di cucina
portata si fa curriculum per ora la lava
i piatti avvocato vediamo innanzitutto
se gianmarco ha preso un buon avvocato
ragazzi sicuro una consistenza pazzesca
che chiamo tutti quanti scusa mete
coincidono lasciando che il frutto lo
contenga ecco mi verrebbe da dire perché
se no se non aggiungo un po d'acqua e
gianmarco loro stesse guarda la magia
che qui secondo me il metodo migliore
per scommettere in generale l'avvocato
tipo far nascere un bambino colonnina di
trans e questo in frigo tenere due
settimane perché una volta che lo mangi
non dire alcuni per la sua restante vita
nei pagargli il college come sei
international comunque perché non
l'avete fatto che cosa avete fatto voi
la scuola guida nella vita aggiungono di
straforo alla cazzo di cane è un po
d'acqua e un po di sale
[Musica]
zucchero sono uguali perché annuncia due
contenitori identici volta di assaggiare
in realtà ragazzi si capisce pure dallo
stato un pochino d'aceto ci metterei
posso dire una cosa che forse vi porterà
ragazzo al di armi io non sono un fan
del risotto
il riso con la crema gli scampi
buonissimo certo mai ripeti la pasta le
vongole il risotto quello lì milanese
era quagliano allo zafferano moressa 6
meno buoni valentino colpita ha messo
tanto amore le ho dato un 6 è un po più
occasionale senza perché ti lancia
sempre il mix di perché noi continua a
cadere il sale ragazzi sempre dalle mani
ieri pure andava bene ma razzante uno
dei condimenti che prende sempre colpo
che insieme alla soia e la major usa b
non so esattamente come si faccia ma
suppongo sia passato il meridione quindi
o queste bustine che trovate facilmente
dal vostro delivery di fiducia che ve ne
porta solitamente 12 in vado a spremere
bello tosto scotto adesso massa quanto
si è gonfiato qui lo lascio a popolare
maionese posa b o di ragazzi e
buonissima io personalmente sono un
amante della lega nord sembra capito
mezzo mangime per pesci però voleva
distinta d'averno e prevenuta visto con
la da subito schifata un po vi ricorda
il cibo per pesci è che tu hai ma
rinomatamente mangiato no questo che sto
facendo e un taglio particolare lo
potete fare a casa a fingere che
presentano voi lo chiamate il vostro
nome
avete visto chiaramente quello che ho
fatto all'inizio lo piegato su se stesso
fino a creare questo tagliate e vi
ritroverete che cosa questa scrive
schiacciata torniamo giu dividete in due
avrete questo che quando andrete ad
aprire saranno tanti piccoli coriandoli
sicuramente non l'ha fatto nessuno nella
storia del taglio
ho solo inventato adesso se voi pensate
che possa avere la paternità non possa
nella possibilità di questo taglia la
uil bus avrà visto un video dove dice
potete appropriarti anche voi
certo certo visto anche un video nel
quale dicono licenze dei familiari
seguirò di più quello che vedo su
internet allora prendiamo il riso enzo a
comporre mi raccomando non fate come
fanno nei ristoranti che vi mettono una
vagonata di riso oriente dove questa
superficie questo substrato di gioia
come i brufoli che c'è la pelle sotto
c'è il bus
praticamente abbiamo un qualcosa di
legoli prato questo qui secondo me è la
cosa migliore l'ho anche un po diviso
non lo schiacciatore tanto secondo me no
vede così con la democrazia che ce la
porteremo avanti il salmone adesso mi
chiamo il mio però del salmone abbiamo
preso già abbattuto a cubetti se volete
farlo a casa vostra fatevelo già spinare
e sfilettare tal pescivendolo di fiducia
tenete in freezer per tre giorni in
questo modo abbattete di qualsiasi
possibilità di prendervi la merda che
c'è all'interno del pesce possibili
virus soprattutto a meno che non sia già
abbattuto come in questo caso era
tristissimo quando lo abbiamo trovato a
questo punto importante insomma inserì
la proteina un titolo fa un povero se le
migliori ristoranti di cucina buttata e
basta passiamo ha lavorato il centenario
così non ci sta convincendo quindi lo
prenderò e lo farò a striscioline sotto
suggerimento di enrico maria semmai
stessi genoa poker al certo punto si
sono scusati piace molto eccetera
molto molto genetico guardate che cosa
vi vado a fare il tocco di colore tutto
quanto un giro di salsa di soia
burri già di spicy maio pellicola laica
potrebbe venire una merda ve lo dico
subito ho capito bene quello che stai
facendo tempo che possa funzionare
mettetevi un like iscrivetevi per darmi
la forza come il congo alza delle nostre
mani al cielo facciamo st genchi da ma
questo si chiama il metodo cui bocelli
brava mamma mia
il metodo queer e questo lo possiamo
chiamare il metodo uil voce sicuramente
46 contento e soddisfatto perché sono un
genio mi rendo conto se vi sentite meno
svegli e pronti mentalmente sapeva di
questo momento che è normale non vi
dovete preoccupare ecco ma sono anch'io
una persona semplice ma non oggi finiamo
con le ultime decorazioni noccioline
apriti sedano bravissimo perché sembra
sesamo faceva ridere con te ma non sai
dove ti ho detto a pretty e tu mi hai
detto sesamo io ho risposto sedano a
qualcuno di voi ha riso lo sai che i
papà pavarotti sono uniti qualcosa sta
ridendo il caso metterne pochi di semi
di papavero perché sono tossici da paolo
cestra con un eroina d'alto mare non
salta proprio droghe pesantissime sia in
data papero il piatto finito come si
dice in francia
ecco io me cojoni che cazzo voi di come
si dice giappone zucca mela
sta arrivando il momento vi darò le mie
impressioni è un altro livello il fatto
che sto fondando e veri sto già
mischiando perfettamente invece
solitamente qua e ancora 27 metri ed
isolare suolo ottimo è un po un problema
o riso basmati non impazzisco per il
riso basmati io preferisco il riso
normale o il riso nero ma è un po che
questa è la barra tipo che che si
trovano in circolazione dove mi piace
sopra la media
scusate tu hai fatto un'analisi per far
ridere per strappare una risata l'unica
che strapperà in cui oggi è ricondurre a
dieta quindi ti faccio un po che al volo
che assaggerà il militare di studi
giudizio in due secondi fatto anche il
tuo molto più tradizionale mi verrebbe
da dire cosa giappone e poi poche
hawaiano per esempio però hawaii
bellissimi colori devo dire con un
cucchiaio cercare di prendere tutto
buono buono ma è sotto la media
il buono lei che se volevate cose sotto
nadia cento che manca qualcosa
ingredienti che gianmarco non ha
comprato certo che ti pigliano da milano
il salmone perde un po a livello di
qualità non è un salmone eccesso l'alga
nori come dicevo ci sta da dio avvocato
ottimo nel complesso sotto la media
perché servite io lo trovo buono credete
renderti così ho mentito solo per far
ridere nel video capito dai facciamo la
linea
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
fidatevi di me
se prendete i buoni prodotti e non
quelli che vita gianmarco il po che
tiene sopra la media se poi gianmarco di
porta tre chiodi 4 brugole per condirlo
quindi sucate anche la minchia come si
diceva in giapponese perfetto ci vediamo
giovedì con un nuovo video
ciao chen di accedere a qualcos'altro da
dire questa è la media
il mio può che sta qui la spesa qui però
è vero a livello di poche siamo sopra la
media la spesa era basso se che era
basso il salmone come si dice in
giapponese
[Musica]